في مقطع منتشر لمسؤول عراقيه او على الاقل
هكذا تعرفت عن نفسها في مقابله تلفزيونيه
هذا المقطع عامل الكثير من الضجه والاسباب
كثيره
بسبب منصبها
اني دكتوره زينب مسؤوله مديره يعني ملف
المؤتمرات والعلاقات الثنائيه مسؤوله
مديره يعني ملف المؤتمرات والعلاقات
الثنائيه مسؤوله همم
دكتوره زينب او مسؤولات مديره ملف
المؤتمرات والعلاقات الثنائيه اسم القسم
يعني بحبها غير بصراحه وما ننسى مع جبل
لكن اكيد لازم نسمع فين هذا القسم موجود
يعني في اي مؤسسه اوكي هنا جاءت عاد
الجزئيه الاعجاب
مسؤوله مديره يعني ملف المؤتمرات
والعلاقات الثنائيه
بالقنصليه العراقيه بجمهوريه اسطنبول
طيب القنصليه العراقيه في جمهوريه اسطنبول
الدكتوره زينب وضحت انها مسؤوله قسم
المؤتمرات والعلاقات الثنائيه في القنصليه
العراقيه في جمهوريه اسطنبول
مثل ما شفته يعني تنوعت ردات يعني فعلا
العراقيين بينضحك وتنكيت على جمهوريه
اسطنبول اللي ما احد سمع عنها قبل
وتساؤلات عن مين تكون هذه الدبلوماسيه ومن
عينها ايش هذا القسم اصلا وطبعا صار في
كلام عن الفساد ووضع الخارجيه الصعب احنا
بحثنا وصلنا لان المقطع من مارس 20 22
وكان متصور خلال فعاليات ملتقى في اسطنبول
كان اسمه الملتقى التركي العربي لمستلزمات
وتكنولوجيا البناء والاستثمار والمشاريع
العقاريه ايش سبب انتشاره الان هذا المقطع
مو معروف لكن العراقيين من الدورين
بالالاف واثار غضبهم او علاقه يعني خلينا
نقول حفيظه